[Música]
en alemania el centrista arm en la 7 es
el nuevo presidente de la unión
-cristianodemócratas cdu el partido de
la canciller angela merkel la 7
reemplaza en el cargo a negro ground
karen bauer y se perfila como posible
candidato a suceder a merkel en la
cancillería tenemos reporte desde berlín
la cifra de fallecidos por el comic 19
superó este viernes los 2 millones en el
mundo y los contagios siguen sin freno
mientras que la uem se alertó de la
situación catastrófica en brasil ante el
colapso y la falta de oxígeno en los
hospitales de la ciudad amazónica de
manaus que vive una segunda ola de la
pandemia peor que la primera
más de 6000 migrantes hondureños
cruzaron a guatemala con el objetivo de
llegar a eeuu los controles policiales
fueron insuficientes para detener la
caravana en la noche del viernes estas
miles de familias huyen de la
devastación que dejó el paso reciente de
dos huracanes el avance del cob y 19 y
la violencia
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina y de todos ustedes que nos siguen
por la señal de france 24
soy alan austria sean bienvenidos
comenzamos en alemania la unión
cristianodemócrata cdu eligió a su nuevo
presidente
se trata de armin las jets cercano a la
canciller angela merkel y es jefe de
gobierno del estado de renania del
norte-westfalia si bien la asamblea
virtual del cdu no se realiza a fin de
elegir al sucesor de la canciller la
elección es de vital importancia para la
era posterior a merkel nuestro
corresponsal en berlín tomas sparrow nos
detalló quién es el nuevo líder y cómo
podría ser su camino en el partido de la
cancillera alemana
la sed se presenta como un político
centrista como un político que ofrece
continuidad de hecho es muy cercano a la
canciller angela merkel y apoyo a merkel
en una de sus posturas más
controversiales la de recibir refugiados
en la crisis de 2015 la 7 es como
ustedes ya mencionaron también el líder
del estado de renania del
norte-westfalia que es el estado más
poblado de alemania con unos 18 millones
de personas y eso es algo que él sin
duda ha presentado como su fortaleza el
haber liderado un estado con una lucha
con mucha importancia en alemania la
pregunta ahora sin embargo es si la zet
también podrá convertirse en el
candidato del bloque conservador de cara
a las elecciones federales de septiembre
eso no es un proceso automático y de
hecho la pandemia ha elevado el perfil
de otros políticos ajenos a los tres
candidatos que intentaban ser líderes de
la cdu y por ello el debate que empieza
ahora es por un lado si la fed podrá
también ser el candidato del bloque
conservador a las elecciones de
septiembre
o si otros políticos como el ministro de
salud james banco o el líder de baviera
marcus ahora podrían ocupar ese puesto
de hecho cuando se les pregunta a la
mayoría de los alemanes y también a la
mayoría de los simpatizantes de la cdu
ese perfil centrista que presenta a la
gente es a lo que ellos quieren mantener
y de ahí que esto pueda ser visto por
muchos dentro de la cdu como una buena
noticia de cara a la carrera que marcará
el final de angela merkel en septiembre
en estas elecciones federales tan
importantes para alemania lado de mesa
advierte que las sociedades de todo el
mundo no están haciendo lo suficiente en
la lucha contra la pandemia en un
momento donde los muertos ya sobrepasan
los dos millones uno de los casos más
preocupantes es el que se vive en la
ciudad amazónica de manaus en brasil
ante el número récord de
hospitalizaciones con su gestión bajo
escrutinio
el presidente yair bolsonaro aseguró que
su administración hizo su parte el
informes de federico que barberena
largas filas por un tubo de oxígeno el
colapso en manaos la ciudad más grande
de la amazonía lanzó a las personas a la
búsqueda desesperada de estos cilindros
para sus familiares hospitalizados con
kobe 19
es para mi abuela que está ingresada en
el hospital se le está acabando el
último cilindro y no sé a qué horas
llegaré a tiempo pero creo que lo voy a
conseguir
estamos buscando la manera de llegar a
la puerta para recibir un tubo para al
menos una semana de vida de una persona
el nivel récord de hospitalizaciones
provocó que ya no haya camas de cuidados
intensivos ni oxígeno en los centros de
salud por eso el gobierno federal
dispuso el traslado de 235 pacientes a
otras ciudades y el envío de oxígeno a
través de la fuerza aérea para el
presidente de jair bolsonaro los
hospitales de manaos siempre están
llenos defendió su gestión y
responsabilizó a las autoridades locales
siempre estamos haciendo lo que tenemos
que hacer
el problema en manaos es terrible pero
nosotros hemos hecho nuestra parte
ofreciendo recursos pero sus críticos
culpan al mandatario por su escepticismo
en el manejo de la pandemia ocupes y su
confianza de ahora es culpa del gobierno
federal por la incompetencia la
incapacidad el haber optado por el
negacionismo en relación con esta
pandemia pero en el caso new's mi hija
la zona sab dónde vive en otro país esto
tal vez sería clasificado como genocidio
brasil mantiene un promedio de más de
en cimientos diarios y acumula más de 8
millones de casos las autoridades
federales esperan iniciar la vacunación
con 2 millones de dosis del fármaco de
astrazéneca traídas desde india un
operativo que ha sufrido atrasos pero
calculan concretar en los próximos dos o
tres días
y precisamente ante los más de 2
millones de fallecidos y las nuevas
variantes del virus las naciones más
ricas concentran sus esfuerzos en las
vacunaciones masivas mientras que la
inmunidad en los países más pobres
avanza muy lentamente cómo van a
gestionar los gobiernos latinoamericanos
una vacunación en territorios tan
desiguales y laia piró médico
especializado en salud pública analizó
para france24
en estos momentos que estamos viendo que
hay millones de personas que están
enfermando y miles que realmente están
sufriendo y muchas de ellas están
realmente muriendo tenemos que utilizar
las vacunaciones de una manera mucho más
efectiva las opciones reales que
nosotros tenemos es ver qué vacunas
tienen un momento para transportación
mucho más efectiva lo que hemos visto en
eeuu con la vacuna de modernas y facer
es que realmente se necesita una
logística muy importante pero también
redes de enfriamiento electricidad y
logística para poder realmente llevar a
cabo esto y también recordar que estas
vacunas en estas dos dosis al momento
que nosotros estamos buscando métodos y
sistemas de salud pública para poder
crear ahora sí que en un país donde
tengamos limitados los recursos es muy
importante reducir las dosis a una y
también la manera de cuidar esas vacunas
que también va a ser crítico para la
transportación logística y
administración de las mismas
parte de los problemas que nosotros
tenemos en este momento es buscar esos
espacios para que realmente las personas
tengan acceso a parte de esto va a ser
justamente la comunicación porque porque
en este momento tenemos que también
vacunarnos contra el miedo con una dosis
de verdad en estos momentos estamos
viendo de estas cosas y aquí busca la
tecnología de las más de 210 vacunas que
están haciendo para aplicarlas a nuestra
comunidad
francia comienza este día con nuevas
restricciones a la vida social en
particular un toque de queda adelantado
a las seis de la tarde según lo anunció
el primer ministro francés yann castex
con el argumento de que es la forma de
no tener que tomar otras decisiones de
forma inmediata y es que el país galo no
ha logrado disminuir el número diario de
contagios
y en medio de advertencias del fbi y
sobre la seguridad del 20 de enero el
día de la juramentación de joe by the
end como el presidente número 46 de eeuu
se han extremado las medidas de
seguridad en la capital estadounidense
con más de 30.000 efectivos de las
fuerzas de seguridad del estado esto
ante una posible ola de actos violentos
durante la semana washington dc se
encuentra militarizada ante esta posible
nueva movilización por parte de
simpatizantes del presidente saliente de
donald trump
en otros temas la caravana de más de
seis mil hondureños que salieron de san
pedro sula con el objetivo de llegar a
eeuu rompió dos cordones policiales en
el punto aduanero el florido y ya cruzó
a territorio guatemalteco en busca de su
meta final
eeuu huyen de la devastación de los
huracanes del cob y 19 y de la violencia
que coincide además con una esperanza de
una mayor apertura migratoria con la
elección en eeuu del presidente de joe
wright informa lluís muñoz
así suena la esperanza por una nueva
vida 6500 migrantes es el número de la
última de las caravanas centroamericanas
que se dirige hacia eeuu según las
autoridades migratorias guatemaltecas
más de tres mil habrían conseguido
cruzar la frontera desde honduras
centenares habrían sido detenidos entre
los que hay familias con niños una
situación de desesperación que supera a
las autoridades fronterizas
incluso llevándolas al despliegue de
militares ya la solicitud de pruebas
negativas para cambiar de país
los huracanes yo está a dieta han dejado
a miles de personas sin hogar ni
subsistencia a esta catástrofe se le
suma el golpe que está suponiendo la
pandemia de kobe 19 para la economía de
los países centroamericanos problemas
que se añaden a la violencia sistémica
de la región tras guatemala méjico y
después el destino final estados unidos
con la ilusión por la elección como
presidente de joe vaivén le pedimos
se llenó de misericordia que dios le
toque su corazón y que abra puertas sólo
queremos una oportunidad para trabajar
los migrantes confían en un cambio de
políticas migratorias respecto a la
dureza de donald trump by den en una
llamada en diciembre con el presidente
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador
coincidió en la necesidad de una nueva
estrategia migratoria una esperanza que
sólo el tiempo confirmará si revierte la
desesperación de los migrantes
centroamericanos o bien si por el
contrario continúan surgiendo nuevas
caravanas
méxico dio a conocer el expediente que
eeuu se entregó al gobierno de andrés
manuel lópez obrador por el caso del
general retirado salvador cienfuegos
tras anunciar que no procesará
penalmente al ex ministro de defensa la
cancillería mexicana dio a conocer este
expediente en el que eeuu acusa a
cienfuegos de cuatro delitos de
narcotráfico y lavado de dinero por
supuestamente haber ayudado al cártel h2
a traficar miles de kilos de cocaína
heroína metanfetamina y marihuana el
presidente mexicano aseguró que no se
hallaron pruebas que lo incriminen y
argumentó que su detención perseguía
objetos objetivos políticos electorales
en eeuu siendo el narcotráfico
uno de los temas constantes de la
campaña presidencial
miles de personas se concentraron en la
capital de haití y en varias capitales
provinciales para pedir al presidente
job en el mois que respete a la
constitución y que deje el poder el 7 de
febrero fecha en que debería acabar su
presidencia esta es la primera jornada
de protestas del 2021 dentro de un
calendario de manifestaciones convocadas
por la oposición en contra del gobierno
del mandatario que asumió el poder en
2017 por un período de cinco años tras
unas elecciones que fueron anuladas en
2015 por denuncias de fraude y que
fueron repetidas en 2016
autoridades palestinas anunciaron las
primeras elecciones en 15 años esto a
través de un decreto que el presidente
de la autoridad palestina mahmud abbas
anunció el llamado a elecciones en un
proceso que comprenderá tres etapas el
22 de mayo está prevista la realización
de las parlamentarias el 31 de julio se
llevará a cabo la presidencial mientras
que el 31 de agosto se estima la
elección del consejo nacional palestino
y finalizamos con el hallazgo del siglo
en bolivia un equipo de investigadores
encontró 45 piezas arqueológicas en la
ciudad prehispánica de tiahuanaco a unos
70 kilómetros de la paz hacia cerca de
200 años que se buscaban este tipo de
piezas probablemente ofrendas rituales y
no se lograban encontrar sin embargo un
equipo de arqueólogos locales lograron
encontrar gracias a la nueva tecnología
el hallazgo se produjo en 2019 pero esta
semana finalmente se presentó para el
público
tallas de rostros cuchillos de piedra
vasijas de cerámica conocidas como
querés después de siglos bajo tierra
regresaron a la superficie del siglo 21
para arrojar luz sobre la civilización
tiwanakota y esta semana por primera vez
se presentaron al público
arqueólogos bolivianos las descubrieron
en 2019 enterradas a 30 centímetros en
la ciudadela prehispánica de tiahuanaco
el material que es importado ahora y el
contexto la información que está
asociada es muy importante para poder ir
avanzando en el conocimiento
inicios de
[Música]
de la entidad política iguana
las piezas 45 en total seguramente
tienen un significado ritual ya que
fueron halladas en un templo de la
ciudadela y científicos y autoridades
esperan que sirvan para conocer mejor la
civilización tiahuanacota estos
hallazgos para nosotros
nuevamente nos hacen aterrizar
es un cable
para volver a ver la realidad de donde
somos
como habíamos sido y más importante
explicar muchas de las cosas de cómo son
hoy
el imperio tiahuanaco se considera uno
de los más longevos de américa del sur
con 2.500 años de historia en el siglo 8
después de cristo se extendió por la
cordillera andina y llegó a ocupar parte
de bolivia chile y perú pero desapareció
después del siglo 12
el porqué de su declive no se sabe cómo
gran parte del pasado prehispánico de
américa latina'
llegamos al final muchas gracias por su
compañía sigue en france 24
[Música]